how's it going res money's perfect you
brothers were crazy for more skate three
and I just love playing this game so
let's play some more I go do you love me
slap that ass slap that ass
come on the slap is coming edge coming
there it is Bob always wins enough
[ __ ] around so there's this whole
love meet thing that you both spoke
about kind of religiously so I'm
expecting a lot out of it okay cool oh
so you can see the damage you do oh it's
all see you get points for killing
yourself oh how do i watch replay I'm a
plane I'm a plane look at me wow look at
this ring come back here [ __ ] hi I'm
coming for you [ __ ] oh yeah free hugs
no one cell phablet though [ __ ]
skateboards who need a skateboard anyway
yes not me son
hi there are you today why is no one
love me notice me senpai notice me
sheriff I know just me
play play notice what is it different
Wow dad from Pluto doesn't would you
like to fly with me I don't care
Eddie what are you doing huh stop this
pause this pause for a man a guy damn
you Baha yeah I'm fine
alright got stuck in his [ __ ] [ __ ]
ha ha ha here we go Oh fabulous
here we go here we go ah yeah if we can
sit down in this chair
no stop close oh my god yeah
ah so comfortable on this chair Oh what
hahaha
you okay there Bob goddamn [ __ ]
hahahahaha
only the sky's the limit go Bob
oh my god you can fly mom is true the
legend is true I'm not sure if that's
how feet work you can literally poop in
your face Bob
oh that's just [ __ ] fresh max is
scaring me
while she's talking about me
I press gonna have to end this episode
here hope you enjoyed watching let me
know if you want more leave it like if
you did I really appreciate it
headless gotta come read today and we'll
see you in the next 1000 res love you
why hahaha oh god that's a sky watch
them oh yeah
voila